okay from
our job continuing tomorrow and I'm
secretly happy Peter I don't think
anybody watching will begrudge me uh the
point that I really did want deep inside
I wanted a rapid tiebreaker because what
a fitting end this would be uh to this
epic epic event as we see h3h5 Magnus
bike played G4 here he might move his
King up
but that's it I mean these moves are
purely symbolic at this point
yeah King E2 played h3h5 played before
black puts everything on the light
squares of course there we go
white has the dark Square Bishop
handshake draw agreed
wow well that kind of game Arc I don't
think anybody quite expected they do
make it to 30 moves but the result of
the game was essentially determined by
Magnus Carlson's opening Choice he plays
a bailout line uh the Four Knights with
this E5 variation leading immediately to
a very balanced end game and a great